all right he's my buddy from the nfl
network one of the best analysts of
talent in the game today certainly one
on television
and fresh off of the raiders making it
1-0 throughout the entire afc west that
includes the chargers whose games that
he calls locally on the radio at move
the sticks from nfl network daniel
jeremiah how are you dj
i'm good man i feel like i'm exhausted
rich from from watching a game that i
really wasn't you know not invested in i
don't work for either of those teams but
it wasn't that wasn't as exhausting a
football game as i think i've ever seen
you know what uh dj um i i led the show
this way and uh i'll just say to you it
was literally like going to vegas it was
literally like a trip like going to
vegas
you know i can tell i can tell you this
and obviously in another life before i
started working for the nfl media group
um but i have never i have never taken a
penny out of las vegas and they've taken
quite a few from me so that's not my
vegas experience no i know i feel
hungover today literally um so
what what is your takeaway from the
monday night week one finale daniel uh
well for my first takeaway big picture
is just how the nfl is king i mean how
great was that it was just you never
know it's so unpredictable it's so fun
yes um i i think the other takeaways the
ravens with all the injuries to go on
the road um
and i you know having worked there and
just kind of know their the kind of the
toughness
mantra that they have when it was at the
you know inches away from winning the
game for the raiders and
and they've already you know lamar's
already shook hands and congratulated
the raiders not winning and then they go
back out in the field and i think
everybody the most people would say it's
a foregone conclusion it's quarterback
sneak once or twice game's over and i'm
saying you're going they don't they
don't cave they do not cave and sure
enough they stunt the line and then they
get a false start and back it up that
ends up being a turnover so
from the raven side of things all very
impressive to to fight the way that they
fought in that game and then from the
raiders standpoint
they they've needed a pass rush forever
and i think with a healthy max crosby
and a healthy yannick and gawkway
that's the best raiders passers we've
seen in quite some time which is very
encouraging especially when you consider
the divisions that play and then a
couple of our buddy mayok's decisions
late that a lot of people were
questioning because they were remaking a
roster
um you know replacing some of his picks
of recent years with veterans kj wright
with a huge fourth down stop uh parriman
made a nice play that was big in the
second half
of the game abram
made that hit
on mark andrews that knocked the ball
loose in overtime it would have been a
first down if he didn't do that
and then the next play was a fumble and
then all of a sudden the game's over
and uh i'm wondering what our buddy you
think he's thinking this morning he was
on the show last week saying that he
would be next to us
next year if they didn't get some wins
what do you think uh the roster and
mayok and the takeaway from last night
looked like just first blush uh well you
know mike would never say anything but i
think it's kind of like there's there's
more there's more that meets the eye
here you know and one of the things i
don't think people talked about and you
have you know this guy's an actor this
guy's no longer on the roster anytime
you bring in a new defensive coordinator
who has a new defensive scheme things
change because you're drafting for what
you do and you're signing free agents
for what you do well that all changed
and it's no coincidence you you
mentioned kj wright guess what he played
for gus bradley so that makes sense for
him denzel perryman played for gus
bradley so you're trying to bring in
players via the draft or free agency
that fit
uh what you do schematically and
coaching wise and so
um that that that happens a lot around
the league with different players uh
when you get coaching changes that some
guys just don't fit as well as others so
that's your job your job is not to make
yourself you know
your record look great in terms of who
you've brought in and how much you've
paid guys your job is to try and put the
best guys on the field to win games and
so
that's that's what they did i know they
got a lot of heat for it but they're 1-0
what do you make of cleland ferrell
being a healthy scratch fourth overall
from just a few years ago
yeah well they've revamped that
defensive front you know um so they've
brought in a lot of new bodies and again
i think with gus bradley it is a real up
the field
um scheme that he wants to run and i
think you know farrell is not he's
turned into a really good run defender
um which you know look in hindsight
should he have been a top five pick no i
we were on the set together i didn't
think so at the time i thought it was a
little bit early um but nonetheless i
think he's still a quality nfl player
particularly against the run he has
value um but you know look they don't
feel like he's uh he's worthy of being
active on game day they've got better
guys and they were pretty competitive
and played well on defense so
um yeah it's unique rich you know any
any anybody if you're a general manager
you don't want your top five pick to be
inactive on on game day i i'm not saying
that's not the case but
you know the results are what matter
they got the win daniel jeremiah here on
the rich eisen show um now the afc west
i mean the chiefs pulled one out um the
broncos put the bang thing on the giants
and then you were physically there in
fedex field calling the chargers game
locally here on the radio what did you
see from the chargers and brandon staley
um that's different what do you see
that's something that's different as
they they came out with the win
yeah well first of all rachel i'm gonna
get to that just a sec but i do want to
let you know i pulled over to in a strip
mall to make sure that we could do this
interview without having to go through
bluetooth and i pulled in front of a
felipe felipe's pizza yes um which i'm
assuming is probably lunch is when that
opens okay and uh and so the guy just
came in here probably the owner and just
stared at me for a good long while like
why does this guy want pizza for
breakfast like we're not open buddy like
come on
you should look at him and say
felipe i watched the raiders and ravens
last night i'm hungry
okay
it's like i went to vegas last night
this is what you do the next morning
like that's what you should what is this
whack job doing sitting i'm the only one
in the parking lot like but you're gonna
have to wait
um no
with the chargers nice
i go back in and you think about justin
herbert in college right rich they had a
pretty good offensive line they had no
receivers
he puts himself into a top 10 pick ghost
the chargers got some receivers
offensive lines terrible he's the rookie
of the year
now we're getting a chance to see justin
herbert with all of his talent
now he's got those receivers back again
with keenan allen who nobody can cover
on third down nobody
um and now with rashaan slater and and
filer um and abushi who played pretty
well they've got a corey linsley who's
you know arguably the best center in the
nfl they have not a good offensive line
but the makings of a great offensive
line and he was outstanding
uh i mean then you flip over to the
other side and you go okay man uh joey
bosa with the pff numbers you can look
him up but you know his his win rate was
off the charts um everybody i mean cosmi
the rookie tackle had no chance against
him so you've got joey bosa healthy
you've got there with james out there
healthy and you're sitting up there in
the booth calling the game and you're
like you know this is a this has got a
chance to be a really really good
football team
when i go back to what we saw last night
with the raiders and the chiefs coming
back to beat the browns the broncos
going on the road
i mean the football on the west coast
right now afc west nfc west perfect
it's perfect it's unblemished and what
you just said about justin herbert and
how
he's in the second year and what a
difference that makes because of what he
went through last year and obviously
when a quarterback gets thrown into the
mix like herbert did last year you don't
see
an offensive rookie of the year campaign
coming but it happens in the nfl
obviously it's rare but it happens isn't
that a cautionary tale
for
matt neggy in chicago throw your guy in
right i mean just do it
why not because
you can obviously
reap the benefits later on next year
start the clock
now and i understand that their line
isn't terrific but the chargers line
last year wasn't
you know
all pro across the board i mean so go
ahead and do it right or am i wrong
please tell me no you you're right this
is the chargers line that tells you what
tom telesco thought of it they have you
know four new starters along that
offensive line for justin herbert's
second season so
um but justin herbert with his
athleticism was able to get away from
some pressure they were able to move him
around
um and he was one of the best you know
third down players in the entire league
he was phenomenal
last year so justin fields to me
i look at it rich and we've talked a
little bit about it but to me are you
mentally and physically tough enough
for what's to come playing behind a bad
offensive line and i think he is i think
he's both and i think he'll give you
some creativity to be able to cover up
some of those blemishes up front
um and i again i want to get his he's
going to make mistakes justin herbert
made mistakes i want to get those
mistakes over with as fast as you can
because i can tell you you know
firsthand having seen it justin herbert
as great as he was rookie of the year
last year this year he is on another
level i mean i saw it going out to
training camp i've seen it in the first
game against a really good washington uh
defense
so let's give him that give him those
valuable reps that valuable experience
so you can get this thing turned around
quicker you know i just to me it makes
all the sense in the world and it's
encouraging that at least they sprinkled
him in that game so we you know got us
he's getting his feet wet a little bit
and maybe that's the thought process
you know kind of gradually get him in
there but man i sure hope it's sooner
than later daniel jeremiah here on the
rich eisen show looking at whatever film
you were able to about the rookie
quarterbacks from week one what's your
takeaway and what you saw oh by the way
you can get a 10 inch cheese pizza
spaghetti lasagna fresh salad and
italian bread for only 24.99 yes we'll
take one we'll take one daniel jeremy
okay very good you're making me hungry
throughout this country
i know it's early in the morning here
but it's five o'clock somewhere okay uh
uh the rookie quarterbacks rich mac
jones was outstanding um i wrote down
when i watched the tape i just wrote
down conviction
and i was talking to orlovsky about this
on the phone yesterday uh and i said
daniel there's a difference between guys
who you know young players who think you
know i think this is where this should
go
versus guys who know where they should
go and you don't you just kind of know
it when you see it and he just has
command and confidence and knows exactly
where the ball is supposed to go so
people some people say well they didn't
really push the ball down the field and
i'm like yeah you know what you can only
pass the test that they need you that's
what they asked him to do and he did it
really really well um so that was
encouraging to me you couldn't find a
better fit for the patriots than mack
jones so that that was that one um you
know we look at trevor lawrence
the the ceiling is so high and there's
some really some some good in there no
doubt um but just no rhythm he had a
couple force turnovers um you know it's
this is new for him with the adversity
that he's that he's facing so um i think
from a bigger picture standpoint it's
kind of bizarre to me that you had the
worst team in the nfl last year
you had all those extra picks
and you know lawrence is the only trevor
lawrence is the only uh rookie starter
for the jags so you know obviously etn
got hurt but you know that was kind of
surprising to me but you know there he's
going to be fine he'll be he'll be fine
but it's going to be a long year for the
jags um uh the jets rich i'm sure you
watched it yeah the first half was was
you know everybody said well it was a
tale of two halves with the way zack
played i'm like really it wasn't even on
him in the first half they were so bad
up front and it was physical beats
getting beat one-on-one fan got beat
one-on-one everyone got beat one-on-one
uh but then miscommunication with the
backs and the tight ends it just looked
like a group that had you know hadn't
really played together very much
um and then in the second half there he
still got hit but they were a little bit
better up front and then you saw him
escape and create and make some things
happen look there's a lot of things to
be worried about with this jet scheme
this year you know through the roster
and injuries and different things the
quarterback is not one of them i thought
he was he was tough he made some big
time throws um i left that game thing
and this kid's going to be really good
you know they've got they've still got a
lot of work to do around him and man the
injury bug rich i don't know what you
guys have done but it has been bad luck
city
yeah i know and bechten went out and you
know it looked like it was season ending
but it looks right now as if it is not
what did you make of
lance and he's how about that the 49ers
first touchdown of the season
uh is is his because he's brought in
inside the ten but jimmy g
uh 300 yards passing on his own what did
you make of of that
usage by shanahan in week one against
detroit
i think i think you're going to see more
of it i think we've kind of predicted
this when we've talked in the past about
just
even if he plays if trey lance plays
three plays you know 20 plays you know
whatever
think about the week of the opposing
team and the effort you have to put into
defending all that you have to defend um
it just is going to be a nightmare
preparing for that team um and what he
brings to the table and it's not like
you know we've seen it you know mariota
came into the game and had that long run
last night
you kind of assume a mario if mariota
comes in the game he's going to be
running the football uh with trey lance
i think that the way shanahan's going to
set it up is he's going to come into
games
and you're not going to know if it's
going to be quarterback power or they're
going to boot him and let him chuck it
down the field i mean
they really have everything at their
disposal in terms of what they can run
um and so i think it's going to be you
know one of the more difficult teams to
defend and and i'll i'll add this you
know you watch trey lansing jimmy
garoppolo was outstanding um emma he's
played well for them when he's been
healthy and i think that was as good as
i've seen jimmy garoppolo play and if
you know you bring in you bring in some
competition like that eventually it's
going to be trey lance's job but i give
jimmy garoppolo credit he didn't sulk he
just he took his game it looks like to a
new level
it it was just a fun
opening week man the whole thing soup to
mutts from last night's finale to you
know obviously from from brady and the
cowboys coming down to the last snap and
then the the first week ends with the
last snap and then everything else in
between before i let you go daniel
jeremiah uh give me a week one
outcome that is indicative
of the larger picture on a positive side
first and then i'll give you i'll give
you a shot to tell me one that that
don't worry about the negative response
so front load the second question first
to give you an opportunity to come up
with the one result that you think okay
this is indicative of
of somebody's uh
2021 season
well last year i was on the kyler murray
as an mvp candidate express
um and he was came out the gates it was
playing outstanding
and then he got you know hurt in the
second half of the season and wasn't
quite the same guy
now you're seeing with the additions of
rondale moore uh to go along with
christian kirk now you've got two
similar guys run after catch guys that
really fit that scheme and then
obviously you've got hot dehop who can
do everything and then whatever you get
from aj green is is is gravy but man if
he stays healthy um that's a that's an
explosive dynamic offense i mean they
put it on the tennessee titans in that
game so that to me was one of those
maybe maybe we were just a year early on
the kyler murray mvp talk so then which
that was a positive outcome okay and
then which one i guess somebody who got
wiped out or or beaten and you're don't
you tell the fan base i guess
ari lax and that's not leading you to
green bay but you can choose them
obviously tennessee um
the browns you know had a troubling end
of a game that was otherwise terrific
you want to give me one on that front
buffalo yeah the browns are going to be
fine i mean they
would love to finish that game and won
that game but
roster wise they are loaded um they are
they have talent everywhere and baker's
not i don't think baker is great but
he's really good um and really good
quarterback play with the rest of the
talent that they have i mean that's as
good a team as they're gonna play all
year with the chiefs so uh the browns
are gonna they're gonna want a boatload
of games
all right dj appreciate the time thank
you uh you move the sticks comes out
today you and uh bucky you're about to
yep
that'll be out today and i do i don't
want to lead you a stray rich the 24.95
price is dine and only okay all right so
we've got to physically go there send us
a
pin your gps for us so we'll know
uh and say hi to felipe for me okay i
will
daniel jeremiah everybody that's a
professional pulling over to avoid the
bluetooth and a spotty cell service and
then eventually finding a gem of fine
cuisine in the same process while
calling into the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here